- [Narrator] Covering the
mountainside in Maras, Peru,
thousands of manmade ponds
sit exposed to the elements,
as they have for over 500 years.
(inspiring guitar music)
Beneath the Qaqawinay mountain,
where these salt pans sit,
runs a salt-filled underground spring.
The pans, each no more than a foot deep,
fill with this natural spring water,
which the sun evaporates,
leaving behind the natural salt crystals.
Created between 500 and 1000 A.D.,
it was the Incans who built
them up into what we see today.
Currently there are
over 3,000 active pans,
each one owned by a different
family in the Maras community,
and are hand-mined much the same
as when the Incans were here.
Each pool yields about 330
pounds of salt per month.
When the salt has been
mined, the pool is refilled
and the process begins again.
Visiting these pans allows you to marvel
at the beauty of nature,
and of man's ingenuity.